were're the puddle jumpers from Stargate
Atlantis just too damn powerful welcome
to sidre your Sci-Fi TV and move
Channel I have said to you lovely people
once or twice before that I actually
think Stargate Atlantis if I'm really
honest to myself might be my favorite of
the three iterations of Stargate sg1
will always hold a special place in my
heart it's the original it's the daddy
in lots of ways it's the best but I've
always felt the Stargate Atlantis was
maybe an evolution of that show that
there were certain things that they
maybe forgot to develop in sg1 that
didn't really make sense one of them
being at no point did they ever put like
vehicles in the Gat room so that they
could go through a Stargate and then do
more than just like walk in distance on
the other side they would travel to a
new world and they explored maybe a few
miles of the gate if it was more than
walking distance they didn't bother they
launched a few drones but that was it at
no point did they ever try to like get a
buggy or anything through the gate so
when they went to Stargate Atlantis the
creators Brad Wright robery Cooper Etc
and Joseph MOSI obviously realized that
this was a little bit of a problem and
really expand the limits of the show
into
Atlantis they needed a plot device to
allow them to explore beyond the base
now I actually think maybe they learned
this lesson from Star Trek Deep Space I
that was a show that was set on a space
station and it was very limited they
couldn't really go anywhere or do much
but then the defiant came into it and
they could and it made for a way more
interesting show it expanded the
Horizons in Stargate sg1 they brought in
things like the Prometheus and then the
Deus and the x302 herself in Atlantis
though they learned that lesson from day
one and we got the little shuttle that
John Shepard called the puddle jumper 8
m long and 4.7 M wide it was designed
specifically to be able to travel
through the gate with engines that were
attractable so they could fit through
the gate very snugly cloaking device
that made it almost impossible to detect
it was quick it was very powerful in the
fact that it had a rechargeable power
source that mean it had very effective
shielding and it had drone weapons um we
believe a minimum of at least 12 of
those drones a very very powerful weapon
on its own and the fact that it had
these drones meant that this little
shuttle that was really able to take on
much much bigger vessels we saw you know
just a handful of drones destroy hatx or
actually even um penetrate the hull of
wraith Cruisers it meant that this small
vessel was able to take on much bigger
starships and much bigger threats if it
needed to you could imagine launching a
dozen of these and maybe even taking on
a hive ship
maybe if you're enjoying the video don't
forget to like subscribe hit that thumbs
up leave a comment and all those things
but also go and check us out on
patreon.com sidre most of our videos do
premere there first a lot of our videos
actually premiere 24 hours before they
do on YouTube so go over check that out
but the puddle jumpers or gate ships as
the ancient called them were actually
really capable Fighters as well they had
a mental interface so that the pilot
could basically just think about what it
wanted to happen and it would just
happen it made it very maneuverable and
very capable in combat situations and
obviously the cloak was a massive
Advantage too but was it too
powerful well it really did seem to be
one ship to fit all situations as a
storytelling device it was kind of
Genius really because they were able to
do so much with the puddle jumpers yes
it was a fighter and a shuttle and a
research vessel and everything else it
had sensors that could detect almost
anything within a solar system it went
on and on and on the vessel really could
do whatever the WR is needed it to do
and for me at times that made it a
little boring we really got to see this
quite a lot in Star Trek as well to be
honest that if there was a problem there
would just be some sort of like
technology they' never mentioned before
that was able to fix it I am adding
virtual particle
trajectories expanding analysis
parameters including Bas and
functions broad em and Subspace Spectrum
polling mm- no change in this case the
puddle jumper really was the Swiss army
knife for the show that really was able
to do anything and then randomly they
would have some sort of like weakness
again there's a plot device for the show
apparently they're quite susceptible to
emps our Fighters today are not
susceptible to emps but that's
electromagnetic pulse by the way
but apparently these vessels are and
even though a puddle jumper could go up
against a wraith Cruiser one-on-one even
sometimes it couldn't actually take on
an RPG launch from a backward people on
some little planet I forget the episode
name but it Lally a poof poof crash so
even though it was an incredibly
powerful transport vessel an incredibly
powerful fighter it did have his
weaknesses so was this just an example
of the writers being lazy well to be
honest no it's a logical piece of
equipment that the Ancients 100% would
have built and perfected over
Millennia if anything the puddle jumpers
weren't powerful enough why didn't they
have zpms on them the zpms only little
they could have had seriously powerful
um energy weapons on board not just the
Pod designs why weren't there fighter
versions of this the Anan had been in a
war for God's sake with The Wraith why
wasn't there a version of the puddle
jumper that just had a massive energy
weapon on it and a zpm if you really
think about it the Ancients had millions
of years to develop vehicles to pass
through the Stargate the Stargate is a
perfect Transportation device for
getting around a Galaxy incredibly
quickly you're going to need something
like a puddle jumper to be able to
extend that reach there's no point
having a gate network if you're just
going to walk through it
sg1 so of course something like the
puddle jumper would be designed and of
course after millions of years of
development it would be a Swiss army
knife for almost any situation but there
should have been different variants of
it for different problems as I say a
fighter variant a much larger transport
variant they also should have been able
to like connect trains to it to like
transport Goods through it should have
been
the um puddle jumper is a you know
engine section and then loads of like
similarly shaped cargo containers after
it that they could just go Z through a
gate and like boom boom boom boom so to
answer the question is the puddle jumper
a massively overpowered plot device
created by Brad Wright and Robert C
Cooper that kind of ruin the show
sometimes because it was just too damn
powerful no it was a device that was
100% logical and if anything not
powerful
enough but guys what do you think about
the puddle jumper and the argument I've
made in this video do you think it was
overly powerful it was a plot device
that allowed the creators to go off and
explore the Galaxy but was it just too
strong or actually did it just make
perfectly logical sense considering who
built the thing or actually should there
have been more variants and actually
maybe it wasn't powerful enough
considering who built it get to the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think about the puddle jumpers as John
Shepard called it or gate ships let's
have a quick vote on that as well puddle
jumpers gate ships tell me what you
think if you are new to the channel
don't forget to like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
citre where most of our new videos do
premere first and you get to see them
without the advert you lucky bunnies
also you can go to c.o. where we do
articles based on a lot of our videos
particularly the exclusive stuff so
please go and check that out too as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next
[Music]
time